[Music]
[Applause]
now if you don't know this is a segment
I think it's very brave of us to do it
this is a segment where viewers we asked
viewers to try to find mistakes on our
show we invite the viewing public to
watch our show with great scrutiny and
see if they can find a mistake so far
hundreds of challengers not one winner
we don't make mistakes it's a flawless
show thank you for buying into that
idiocy well tonight a fan named chase
ledger would says he thinks he caught a
mistake he says it happened during a
recent comedy bit hello Conan
I was recently watching her segment
BuzzFeed is running out of lists when
you showed this list thirteen endangered
species that were kind of asking for it
I like this one thirteen endangered
species that we're kind of asking for it
I hate the four tail badger yeah number
one on this list is a pork tailed badger
that pictures of the endangered
Tasmanian Devil worked a badger does not
exist so it appeared for the next three
seconds but I've wondered
he's a kid
[Applause]
[Music]
no no no no your please it's a child my
point is this kid why are you whispering
its I think he broke into a house is
nuts if we're gonna begin to shoot his
fan correction or he's ashamed of
contacting maybe I don't know either way
I hate to tell you this cuz you seem
like a nice kid but chase you are dead
wrong you are dead wrong okay you say
it's a Tasmanian devil but I know for a
fact it's a fork-tailed badger now sure
European settlers called it a Tasmanian
devil but the animal had a name long
before the Europeans got to Australia
and here is an actual Aboriginal woman
living deep in the Australian outback
who will back me up
you know me and a nobody a Motorola
trinocular on Jane Doe I'm on earlier
when you order your aluminum body
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to the challenge still stands if you
think you spotted an error on our show
reported team coca calm / haha I found
an error we will sort it out right here
on the air let's see if you've got what
it takes to make junk meat out of the
maestro ladies
[Applause]
you